lui c'est iricéo 33 ans il est né le 2
novembre 68 mais qu'importe aujourd'hui
ça va être sa fête dans la ville et
cuisiniers ça tombe plutôt bien l'équipe
de Pascal selem lui a concocté une
journée d'enfer pour le moins gratiné
notre complice et Florence sa femme
nous a donné carte blanche il est 4h du
matin tout le monde est en place
objectif installer les caméras et les
micros on a eu le double des clés et je
cache un micro dans sa voiture en
attendant la sortie de chez lui
il va prendre sa voiture mais devant sa
voiture il va avoir René il est où mon
René René
personne ne sort de ces caches pour le
moment
[Musique]
6h30 Thierry sort de chez lui avec 5
minutes de retard pour commencer la
journée il a un rendez-vous inattendu
René notre clochard s'est endormi devant
sa voiture et équipé d'une oreillette
Pascal le dirige dans ses moindres faits
et gestes actions
[Musique]
tire-toi et bouge de là
c'est quoi c'est quoi ce bordel là
dis-lui je vous laisse partir c'est bon
ne doit pas être trop porteur à son
travail la journée ne fait que commencer
et le planning est chargé il y en a même
qui ont de la suite dans les idées
n'est-ce pas parce que
on va lui pourrir la journée
deuxième lieu du crime la boulangerie la
boulangère les caméras la radio il est
9h l'équipe installe le piège de la
boulangerie dans une heure Thierry doit
passer pour récupérer une commande bonne
occasion pour lui tendre un piège
[Musique]
Pascal justement et Florence la femme de
Thierry ont préparait un jeu radio un
peu particulier à peine remis de ses
émotions clochardesk il est 10h Thierry
arrive je vais chercher les gâteaux pour
la mairie
allez comme promis on va jouer au c'est
qui qui t'appelle et nous composons au
hasard un numéro de portable
[Musique]
ça sonne
allô allô
[Musique]
votre numéro de portable a été tiré au
sort et on va peut-être vous faire
gagner jusqu'à 50 000 francs vous
appelez comment Florence Théo
alors Florence attention première
question
quelle est la capitale du Suriname
la capitale du Suriname
des collègues voulaient vraiment le
hasard
bravo et dites moi Florence au témoins
d'ado vous n'avez pas un dictionnaire à
côté de vous quand même pas du tout non
non attention pour 10000 francs Florence
en quelle année Charlemagne a-t-il été
sacré empereur
alors Charlemagne secret empereur
il me semble que c'est en l'an 800
vous venez Florence de gagner 10000
francs mais attention
oserez-vous mettre cette somme en jeu
j'ai réussi à te regagner jusqu'à 50 000
francs question à 50 000 francs 59
francs 50 en février alors vous êtes
prêtes Florence pour 50000 francs
quel est l'acteur principal du film
Piège de cristal
[Musique]
il aime évidemment ses enfants et fumant
et faire de tout il adore c'est sa
petite Twingo avec son autocollant om en
tarte maintenant il manque la ceris sur
le gâteau ou plutôt sur la voiture il
est 11h nos équipes s'improvis
supporters du PSG et vont droit au but
pour Thierry fan de l'OM la foi et de
taille
[Musique]
je trouve qu'il y a pas assez le bordel
dans la maison le c'est lui au
même moment il organise le cambriolage
dans la maison de Florence et Thierry
il est midi la tension monte c'est
l'accident
s'il te plaît
un micro sur le portable de Florence
[Musique]
et puis là je repars là je suis je suis
dehors au parc
ouais ça va sinon ouais
[Musique]
mais qu'est-ce qui t'a fait ça
j'ai eu un jeu sur sur la radio
tu m'as entendu
[Musique]
tu devais être vert
tu finis à quelle heure
ne crois pas si bien dire 5 minutes plus
tard Florence le rappelle une fois de
plus Thierry tombe dans le panneau d'une
journée d'enfer une image
je suis à la maison là il y a la police
qui est à la maison et on se serait fait
cambrioler
tu peux tu peux venir
[Musique]
notre victime est vraiment sur les nerfs
il n'est pourtant pas au bout de ses
peines il est 13h15 Thierry arrive chez
lui pour planter le décor une voiture de
police mais la surprise se trouve
vraiment à l'intérieur
bonjour monsieur
bonjour bonjour monsieur police
nationale
bien on a été prévenu en fait par une de
vos voisines comme quoi apparemment il y
avait eu un cambriolage bébé tu avais
commandé quelque chose ce matin j'ai eu
un
livreur qui sont venus mon livret de ce
carton là et maintenant il est vite je
sais pas ce qu'il y avait tu avais
commandé quelque chose
vous êtes partis
la seule chose qui nous embête un petit
peu c'est que pour l'instant nous on est
arrivé ce matin il y avait aucune
effraction qu'est-ce que vous avez
confiance à des gros chiens non c'est
d'ailleurs qu'on fait ça des espèces de
faux cambriolage ça arrive quand même
assez souvent des gens qui veulent en
fait faire passer un certain nombre de
choses et qui simule un cambriolage donc
on est obligé
de partout
pas toutes les patrouilles pas trop les
1 à toutes les patrouilles
ce matin donc c'est bon
cambriolages dans le secteur
oui patrouille 2 nous sommes sur un site
212 est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
votre position s'il vous plaît
on est juste à côté on est au 2 bis rue
des Érables est-ce que vous pouvez
passer pour une vérification terminé
si vous pouvez trouver des actus
mais j'en sais rien
si vous voulez bien si vous voulez bien
nous suivre
il est 17h c'est peut-être le moment
d'annoncer à Thierry enfin une bonne
nouvelle
la journée
[Musique]
non parce qu'à la maison on a un gros
carton que j'ai reçu ce matin il était
hyper lourd et
il y a rien
c'est sûr c'est lui comment tu es rentré
dans l'appartement toi tu es rentré dans
cet appartement ou pas je crois que
c'est le moment du dénouement parce que
là il comprend plus rien du tout mon
poste tu étais dans le carton
on sait même pas
non mais c'est ça il était dans le
carton c'était dans le carton tu es
sorti du carton tu as mis le bordel et
tu as tout pris
à la radio
[Musique]
une journée d'enfer